[Music]
opening shot is an opening eye cliche my
name is Alice
like most sequels these days movie feels
the need to literally recap the previous
film for the first few minutes how do we
know they're evil they're driving in
single file in black SUVs and tailgating
hey fun fact just a few blocks over in
this fake-ass city is the house Truman
lives in and a few streets past that
Indiana Jones is hiding in a
refrigerator
well here's possibly the most dangerous
possible way to display information
inside a moving car
cement truck guy might be the drunkest
cement truck guy ever filmed and
whoever's driving this SUV probably had
a six-pack as well on a bright sunny day
in the middle of the city with no
traffic somehow this happens oh come on
you guys somehow found a way to drive
back all in a single-file from different
parts of the city and it's still
daylight outside I don't think so
disgraced cop pins all her newspaper
clippings on a bulletin board for
motivation and to randomly inform an
unseen audience man I wish there was an
explanation for those unexplained
killings so that this story would be
more contradictory than redundant
fighting zombies in resident evil
requires wearing tomb raider gear all
the zombies are in Clear View for Jill
to mow down like she's at a carnival
shooting gallery that's rigged for
success rather than failure this is
easily the 11th best into a speaker zoom
I've ever seen does she have it in a
contract that she won't do a movie
unless it contains the scene where she
wakes up in an observation chamber
barely dressed in some kind of white
covering this outbreak could not have
lasted long enough for the newspaper to
keep printing daily updates on it it
lasted about 13 hours right the city is
completely contained sir our troops have
sealed all exits the only way out is
across this bridge so they set this up
in 13 hours they somehow built a
perimeter around the city and a huge
fortress at this bridge complete with
mechanical doors in 13 freakin hours you
better take a look at this cliche
because one kick is all it takes no and
that was the story of the unimportant
character who died that one time
zooming technology military guys
realized they wasted their time and
hours
fu lady you look like a chick who just
turned down ten losers in a nightclub
not a respected member of the police
force we've known this character for two
scenes and in each her only visible
treat is the one who kills the zombies
when everyone else is pushing out movie
turns into the music video for NES
Orinoco flow the script for the Sony
movie began with the idea guy opens up
his vaio laptop they filled in all the
zombie stuff around this scene hack
search okay
they had this homing beacon software but
just told him they couldn't find his
daughter anywhere it's no surprise that
the British Jared Harris gets a chance
to play Big Brother in this adaptation
of 1984 with zombies hany motorcycle and
completely opened guns and ammo store
ready for the zombie apocalypse also
alice is apparently the only citizen of
Raccoon City that had the idea to read
the gun store during the zombie
apocalypse Alice remembers everything
about the weird experiments they did on
her when she was drugged and probably
knocked out most of the time I can
barely remember what I did last night
sober the last time we saw these guys
they were frantically running away from
gunfire in a wild mob scene somewhere
between then and now the reporter found
Jill and Payton again and they're all
best friends now it does make a cool
shot but modern churches do not actually
leave thousands of lit candles burning
24/7 it's a significant fire hazard
dramatic thunder and lightning is
dramatic Sachiko did my Emmy
reporter announces her certain death in
this movie by finding ways to be selfish
during a zombie apocalypse also
weatherperson dreams of being a serious
reporter cliche these guys hear a noise
in a church and think it's a zombie for
some reason instead of Jesus as per
usual on a day that was reportedly 92
degrees old ladies like to sit by the
fire so that if anyone comes into the
room they're zombie appearance won't
immediately be seen for suspense
purposes what do you do train badass cop
doesn't look for other people in the
room and has no peripheral vision
whatsoever also Jill asked the zombie
lady and this dude didn't bother to say
anything at that moment he was just
waiting in the wings to pop out of
nowhere I guess also where the hell did
this guy come from you see this room it
doesn't have any other doorways or
hallways or any place where zombie
caretaker priest could possibly hide
movie quickly reduces size of a playing
field of entire city to much more
manageable single Church
discount the graduate zombie NASCAR also
this unholy creature sired by umbrella
has apparently been sitting here the
whole time waiting for the movie to say
it's okay to show up now discount
predator can it's only been on this
earth for a few hours but it already
knows the movie distractions playbook by
heart how many pages of this script
contain the simple line one of the
characters wanders nervously in a church
I'll tell you sixteen of them sixteen
six fifteen teen asshole Peyton decides
the best way to handle this situation is
by rapey methods instead of a whisper
we're gonna need more you know what else
we're gonna need a story this is like
Michael's out of nowhere appearance in
underworld evolution and my fault just
shy of the Bulls Jeep through a psych
ward seen in the 18:4 ridicu convenience
also does the church have a stunt ramp
somewhere outside and how Alice know to
come here and to this very spot in the
church motorcycle also functions as an
elevator the only way you can make the
follow the bullet shot fun anymore is if
you have tiny gremlins riding the
bullets for absolutely no reason at all
otherwise it's just a slow way to fill
in bullets see now you just wasted your
motorcycle stunt on one monster there
are two more monsters where's your
motorcycle now are you person who should
be grateful that the deus ex machina
literally came into God's house on a
machine angrily demands answers see this
is why we can't have nice things
also movie panders to the
african-american demographic and throws
one recognizable black actor in this
thing so he can do all the stereotypical
black guy things movie takes a page from
angel heart and gives you some awesome
nudity bathed in penis confusing blood
forty five percent of all car accidents
are caused by bloody titties also I'd
like to know the circumstances by which
these hookers had their tops off were
they bitten by zombies and during the
time before they turn they never put
their tops back on and state hookers oh
yeah there are other people in this city
I completely forgot
I honestly don't know why they didn't
just use more grenades during this fight
these zombies pretty much traveling pax
Raccoon City could not afford to put a/c
on their police cars the director of
this movie found a book on classic cool
shots slam the book on the table and
said I will do all of them in one movie
I guess Alice never answered that
question Jill asked about who the hell
she was and they started walking through
this graveyard which let's be frank is
probably the safest place during a
zombie apocalypse those things okay just
because you worked at umbrella does not
mean you instantly know how many of
these monsters got out and where they
would decide to go in this huge city
also if we take a word on this and that
was really all of them and why did these
things show up at the church where they
just trying to get baptized or something
discounted
the bad and the ugly I guess umbrellas
t-virus is now soaked into the ground
this is actually the scary part I don't
think this one has the debuggers it's an
actual freaking zombie which means a
zombie apocalypse was about to happen
with umbrellas help or not
also impending zombie apocalypse
conveniently happens at the exact time
as manufactured umbr.ella zombie
apocalypse you've seen these things not
even slowed down when they get shot but
twice now we've seen simple kicks take
them down when they first started
walking through this graveyard Alice was
wearing a full pair of jeans
now as the fighting begins she's got
half a pant on this hand-to-hand combat
is well it's the best thing this movie
has offered up so far but still what's
the fucking point you can't defeat all
of them this way and any second now one
of yous gonna yell run to escape the
whole horde but whatever fighting is
what we came for right no what do we
come for again all you need to know is
that zombie asses were kicked by females
any details beyond that you're kind of
an asshole for wanting to know actually
all right she killed that one zombie
only one hundred thousand ago how did
you not notice their numbers before you
started fisticuffs uh-huh irony also I
guess this dude came out of the ground
and said forget I am too damn tired to
join this movement then worms this
presents a perfect opportunity activate
nemesis program now it's not really a
perfect opportunity it's just that you
wanted to find any way at all to
introduce yet another classic Resident
Evil baddie in this movie zombie stuff
can get boring so it's time to throw a
new evil thing to the mix how can you
have all this amazing data about the
spread of the t-virus when you have a
connection failure let's get Yuri Yuri
in the hospital did you see it
maybe a radio wonderful works say jury
yeah take carry Yuri's the lifeblood of
this movie hold on you yeah hold on Yuri
I won't be able to get through this
without your winning smile and he tells
the best jokes they killed Yuri movie
kills the best character in any movie
franchise ever this guy knows damn well
that's not a zombie but who's gonna play
the blame game during an apocalypse we
all know there's no way that guy saw a
zombie behind Mike Epps otherwise why
don't you yawn and say dude there's a
zombie he get down damn isn't there one
racist in this whole group of white
people God knows why nemesis decided to
show up here he was like if I were stars
guys in the middle of a zombie
apocalypse where would I go to the
theater also he totally missed out on
the two stars guys back at the hospital
you know those guys whose main mission
in life was to help URI with his dreams
and aspirations they were right there
when he picked up his weapons and he did
nothing nothing I tell you
tactics and Rescue Squad the best
currently the best are standing in clear
view of a monster holding a bazooka I'm
not ready to give them Navy SEAL status
just yet this evil dude is apparently
immune to bullets how much one about
Alice takes him out with a kick I know
that nemesis isn't aiming for Mike Epps
and we're supposed to believe he has
terminator styling but he's just
shooting blankly into a theater right
now if we mapped out the paths of these
five thousand bullets being shot it
would create a perfect outline of Mike
Epps so how many hit points is gonna
take to kill this dude now it did
something to me I barely feel human
anymore
phone rings out of nowhere so that
whatever happened to Alice will remain a
big mystery until the end Peyton is
playing the Michelle Rodriguez of this
movie the person who was good but won't
change into a zombie until the movie
needs them too does the T Pirates know a
good person and just drag out the
process and well we know they can't
contain the infection record city will
be completely sanitized Alice doesn't
speak like a normal person so the teri
has to ask what the hell sanitized means
he's watching us on these cameras like
this is some kind of sick game huh it is
a game nemesis is the luckiest bounty
hunter since Bubba Fett pretended to be
trash to track the Millennium Falcon
okay her threat is minimal oh she turned
around it's moderate now does it live is
this what we've been waiting for you're
saying this is all so you can watch a
nemesis face off against Alice because I
can think of thousands of ways to
achieve this without killing the whole
city nemesis decides F I'll wait for a
worse time to start shooting at her
badass Nemesis project soldier can't aim
for slowest rocket ever even if you did
know she was right here in this hallway
why is this the best choice for entering
the building her gunshot enough of a
hole to fit through and what a
convenient garbage disposal let that be
a lesson you can survive bazooka blasts
by hiding in a rubber trash collector
this chick has been presented as nothing
short of badass but she's struggling
more than I would to hotwire a car
who does this we're assets Nikolai
expendable assets and we've just been
expended Resident Evil C will give
Sylvester Stallone ideas man Mike Epps
is like God or Derek Jeter the guy's
just everywhere ha ha
dodge spent money on a product placement
in this piece of crap also did they know
ahead of time that their vehicle was
gonna share screen time with a Pontiac
you might as well have a homeless guy
outside screaming there are zombie dogs
in that school beware
no doubt this school is big but if you
split up don't you run into a situation
where someone finds the girl you have to
waste time looking for everyone else
after that what a bunch of nonsense
NASCAR zombie 500 race continues
uninterrupted absurd come on I know he
was called here but do you know what the
chances are Carlos found the exact room
day-day was in and was able to save him
at the last minute it is a noted fact
that zombie dogs only bite the hands and
when you're being attacked by these
creatures it's only natural that you
seek refuge with world maps stupidity
and suddenly hundreds of zombie kids
appear I mean seriously these are some
ninja ass zombie kids also how did they
find 1990 Joseph gordon-levitt I bet
they went on an excellent adventure with
Bill and Ted person who was filming gets
attacked and we pan down to see the
dropped camera still rolling and pointed
at the exact perfect direction cliche
entire school budget went towards
basketball purchases this girl got in a
car accident the first thing she does is
go back to school I guess she walked
absolutely no injuries after being hit
by a cement truck and flipped several
times and then she turns into this
movies version of Newt I got that right
also how did the zombie kids miss this
other alive kid Sami dogs finally make
an appearance only because Jill decides
to go back through the school a
different way than she came
seriously why not go back the direction
where there was obviously no conflict
you gotta be kidding me with a sheep
school that is so huge that Jill told
everyone they needed to split up to find
the girl becomes super small when it
comes to needing a convenient gunman at
the right time haha because that's what
you say to dogs that's amazing did you
learn that from Yuri I do it was filled
with awesome quips to say when you kill
things guttural noises hemoglobin what
the hell is this bitch doing under the
stove once again Alice shows up to a
place and can't possibly have a clue
what's going on but here she is
cigarette ready to burn gasps she can't
possibly know is there she brought a
fireproof blanket too didn't Jill get
under the blanket that's what I saw on
my brain believe but movie says nope
that didn't happen oh god here we go
rack focus villain is rack focused you
really thought I didn't know well yeah
you let him get this far for no damn
reason at all so yeah that's reasonable
actually
I'm not contagious when did this become
a love story again yeah take the story
I'll see that it gets but see gays I
know when I'm in the middle of a zombie
apocalypse it occurs to me to give
someone a dead person's camera so they
can record it my name is Alice yeah we
saw this earlier skipped how did she get
on this roof with no one seeing her
Alice kicks this dude then the remaining
three guys not only attack one by one
they notice her one by one yes these
guys can't hear with their helmets on
for Alice's sergeant York either way
this is about as much buffoonery as i
can take what's the rush
good god where did this asshole come
from how many times do I have to say
this in this movie there's no way
they'll get out of these babies that's
for sure now we discover which is
superior screenwriter gives up in the
third act and just says let's just have
a celebrity deathmatch douchebag
earpiece fightin this whole movie was a
setup for Alice to fight nemesis it
makes very little sense nemesis was
awakened before they even knew about
Alice and even then the reasons for
waking and we're never all that clear
other than fanboy masturbation man
there's nothing better than when a
massive creature a lady infected with TB
iris box for our amusement it's like an
underworld when the werewolves and
vampires fight with guns it's completely
and totally absorbing then I see
absorbing I meant boring also movie
builds up to this fight and is really
only interested in showing you a quick
edit of a punch here a quick edit of a
punch there some stuff you can't make
out and probably a splice dick in here
somewhere
but I'm not entirely certain and you are
one terrible scientist all the evil
things you've done I can forgive but
this is an experiment between two of
your creations you can't throw another
variable into the mix and get accurate
results
that's cheating the scientific method
man who could possibly reproduce your
results remembering things also yet
that's the dude from the first movie
they turned into this ungodly beast I
guess I should care but it's really
really hard to do so finishing Resident
Evil decides to go all mortal combat on
us I'm gonna call her Sonya Blade so
down twice back forward ex get nemesis
the kiss of death the dream came true no
one notices this somewhere around in
here I have to ask where is the military
are these evil umbrella guys one of the
same with the military we saw our PD car
as a separate police force for the city
from the umbrella people so at what
point does the rest of the world take
notice of the apocalypse happening in
record city and come help out Mike Epps
can punch and knock out a man sitting
down from the pilot's seat through the
entrance with his left hand
it's pretty damn amazing movie has gone
to such senseless overload I barely
register that these guys aim is once
again so awful it's barely worth noting
but worth noting it is she even end up
behind glass inside a building anyway
the helicopter had no problem trying to
shoot her but three guys who have the
drop on or hesitate for unknown reasons
amazing skills include beating gravity
to the punch where did the helicopter go
that was shooting at her why did it stop
shooting at her why am I still expecting
anything resembling common sense in this
movie they must have digitally removed
the hail of bullets that should be
killing her right now Domino explosions
random flying debris has better aim than
people who were trained for combat in
this movie did she and Matt even fall in
love in the last movie he revealed
himself to be a secret environmental
terrorist they fought some zombie demons
on the train they were captured in the
mansion why is she so broken up about
this guy's fate but let it Justice
didn't they shoot this missile forever
ago
detonation in t-minus five minutes I
gotta hand it to him it took almost
exactly five minutes a movie for that to
happen but way more than five minutes of
real things have happened so fudge it
human with amazing reflexes decides to
catch this inter stomach rather than in
her hands and that's understandable they
crash landed on these soft rocks we have
unconfirmed reports of disaster at
Raccoon City ah I see the rest of the
world finally caught wind of going down
here too bad it took a nuke to make that
happen
Luger refuses to end anywhere near or
even a few minutes after a logical place
damn they can't make her forget anything
can they my name is Alice
everything I mean who do you think I am
Jason Bourne sure she can turn back time
to anything is totally possible now also
damn that was cold-blooded she punched a
bunch of dudes back at the lab but the
security guy he's getting his eyeballs
blown out where did she get a robe her
newfound telekinesis could not possibly
work in this situation
let them go this dude just woke up no
one told him what happened how does he
know that Jill Carlos and Mike Epps
saved her and are now attempting to
drive out of here does the lab have
security cameras even so he just woke up
program is activate there's no way
she'll get out of this pickle can't wait
to see the third movie where it will
probably take five minutes for her to
get back to normal again Paul WS
Anderson
[Music]
because 7,500 is nothing to you do you
know how the rest of us live and in the
end who's been harmed the cartoon peril
was no more
[Music]
[Applause]
most of the intelligence community
doesn't believe he exists the ones that
do call him the Winter Soldier
[Music]
Leeloo Dallas multipass he will die
tonight Khaleesi request immediate
backup maximum response you have to
speak up I'm wearing a tow let's talk
about Harry no not that Harry definitely
not that Harry what know people I'm
talking about razors if you're like me
you hate spending money and leaving the
house
Harry's can help with both of those
issues by sending cool little packages
of quality razor blades they craft
themselves right to your door for half
the price of regular razors and blades
most of us guys need to shave most so
why not spend less money and effort on
it by going to harrys.com today if you
enter the promo code cinemasins
they'll even give you five dollars off
your first order what I'm sorry I wasn't
listening that's Harry's com promo code
cinemasins do it go things razors
excitement
[Music]